I see that the reason that we have a
good discussion on sustainability issues
is because that a lot of companies have
adopted sustainability strategies as an
integrated part of the business
proposition so therefore I think that
business a lot of businesses are the
drivers of this debate and demonstrating
that it really is a business opportunity
in being very sustainable so I think
that global businesses really have taken
this responsibility upon them that
doesn't mean that this is a general
picture but again I feel that business
have been a key driver have been an
important driver in setting this
sustainability agenda and demonstrated
that it can be done and it's worthwhile
and that businesses have a self-interest
so bottom line we owe to the front
runners in business that we have a
realistic and future orientated debate
on on sustainability in corporate life
there's a widespread of companies all
over the world working with us it's very
hard really to pick somebody in stir and
say these are the leading because there
are many leaders in Denmark I mentioned
one company for example no one orders a
big pharmaceutical company one of the
biggest producers of insulin for them
sustainability is not only a part of the
corporate social responsibility that an
integrated part of their whole business
Trinity because working with diabetes
patients it is necessary to look at and
adopt sustainability as a really
essential competitive edge so this kind
of companies will it demonstrate that if
you're working with some of these value
driven markets value driven problems you
can't do it you can't work with these
without adopting sustainability as a
core business strategy so they benefit
from it they can't survive they can't
develop without that for example another
could be Walmart in United States one of
the biggest retail store in the world
they work with it and I'm quite sure
when they do that and they come in the
last few years and really to promote
that in the whole value chain they do
that because they feel that they need
out there among customers and interest
about costumers to do so and it's part
of their position in society that they
adopt this kind of strategies so these
are small things example and a worldwide
example but they are united in the same
approach and same understanding up that
sustainability is a core issue a
necessary issue for any business who
wants to stay in business and want to be
sustainable business themselves so I'm
quite sure that a lot of companies
we follow that path
I think that business should collaborate
in win their value chains because in
like the example of is with Walmart here
you have me accept that in the value
change the different business partner in
the value chain they be part of it so
this is a very very important part where
business can they collaborate that if
they have a huge company say this is our
strategy that's what we want to do then
they have to adopt the strategy to the
whole value chain and they are fine sure
that the value chain the whole value
chain is based on sustainable issues and
you can see that Unilever I know will do
that
become and they work with sustainable
sustainability as part of their value
chain and this is a very important part
it's very important example because this
example tells me that if one company
really can document this is a very
necessary element in our business
strategies they can only do that if
there is if the same approach is
followed by the only other parts of the
chain and and therefore this is the only
way you could be credible because if you
as a main company say we are sustainable
but you are partners in the value chain
and then you're not credible so there is
a natural business like interest in
creating this so I think that the best
partnerships the best collaboration
should be when the value chains
you